Allah the kumoemon c'mon sir - slowly
Allah Allah current Indian drinkin is
against royal cousin do
she's a Seneca to Royal es creme de
escala you allele emulsions ma perfecta
yogi Jensen [ __ ] Rena yoga can innovate
a Yahoo gets royal get coeruleus cannon
perfect
okay courtesy built in whren yacht in
Honolulu L dynamic pool yera possible a
sista bina steadiness tears yamuna
moneda yes giganto a hidden immunity
movie Oh yo yo yo amo demuccio perfect
ur emo voila we saw Nando make one of
the most delicious most impressive kinds
of emulsions aioli it only is like a
garlic mayonnaise it's very simple
ingredients it's garlic salt and olive
oil and what he does is he mixes the
salt in with the garlic and it crushes
the garlic the salt pulls the water out
of the garlic and then the water from
the garlic garlic acts as a surfactant
to stabilize the drops of the olive oil
in the water and you saw a Nando slowly
mix them together he crushed the garlic
he pulled the water up and he slowly mix
the olive oil in slowly emulsified it
and ultimately he made a solid emulsion
the only way the emulsion can be solid
is if he emulsifies sufficient olive oil
that you get this highly compressed
drops so they become elastic they become
solid and if you watch Nando make it
sometimes what he'll do is he'll say the
emulsion is about to break just as he's
finishing it I mean takes a few drops of
water and adds it to the emulsion the
reason for that is that you're so close
to phase and version you have so much
olive oil and so little water that it
can easily phase invert and instead of
having drops of oil in the water you
have huge number of drops of oil in a
relatively small amount of water and you
can end up with drops of water in oil
then you have a very small amount of
water as drops in oil but you don't have
an emulsion and you don't have a solid
now a simpler way of making an aioli is
to add a surfactant garlic is not the
best surfactant that's why it's very
difficult to make a true eye only to
make it much more easily
what nonde did was he added a really
wonderful surfactant so he took an egg
yolk he mix it with the garlic in the
water and that then could much more
easily emulsify all of the olive oil
without the egg yolk it's called allioli
and that's the most simplest form of an
emulsion it's also to me one of the most
impressive forms of emulsion because
it's so little so few ingredients and
yet you get the solid garlic like
mayonnaise eventually however emulsions
will fail so let's understand a little
bit about what it means to have an
emulsion fail in order for an emulsion
to fail you have to lose the drops of
one fluid in the second so you have to
lose the drops of the oil in the water
and there are several ways that this can
happen the first thing that will happen
is the fact that the oil and the water
have a different density typically the
oil is lighter than the water eventually
the oil drops will come to the surface
this will particularly be the case if
the volume fraction is relatively low
and there are several ways that this can
occur the most obvious way is through
coalescence two drops come close to one
another and they join together and form
a larger drop always for the failure of
an emulsion you have to lose the drops
and so the drops have to become larger
it's the small drops that give the
emulsions particular character but there
is another more pervasive way that
emotions
and failed and that drops can grow and
that is called Oswald ripening and that
is absolutely pervasive it's almost
impossible to completely eliminate
Oswald ripening fortunately it's a
relatively slow process so it's not so
important oftentimes unless you store in
emulsion for a very long time and Oswald
ripening is the transfer of fluid from
one drop to another drop and remember
drops are at a higher internal pressure
than the outside and the pressure inside
the Laplace pressure increases as the
drops get smaller so there's a driving
force an increased pressure to drive the
fluid from the small drops into the
large shots